such a good team defender especially on
screen role games I think he's one of
the really underrated big matter with me
bad shot bingo yikes ugly one of the
better defenders in the league
Paul George one of the better offensive
players in the league George gets that
one to go down off this short George the
rebound a little bit of time here for
the Thunder I'm gonna check the replay
but Paul George at the buzzer the third
quarter at his place quarterback is the
de George George season down the
buzzer-beating truth Wow with an
eight-point lead if sir biggest spread
they scored the last nine points of the
half you're happy with this because you
know the offense is working the defense
is making things happen
this year three white shirts off the bag
excavation bring in it emphatically
slamming at home this is just an
apartment well you know
behind you that can make that play
that's just such a good collective
effort set it up to his teammates Jeremy
grant he can get up with the rest of
them for the highlight reel this is
great hustle great hustle and having fun
stay done by dentistry getting back here
come the funding of numbers sugar tops
it up George
[Applause]
here's a top photo the city this break
Steven Adams started it with the
turnovers Durant
what Diallo swaps Durant tried to go
behind the back it ends up in the hands
of George Weber stuff good thing just
for a easy look for the nets
some ball movement they don't think out
off six field goals Paul George soaring
high for the Thunder gets it in for
Westbrook one-point game whisper tosses
George
[Applause]
the Thunder gone front with three
seconds to play to play comes in to
Russell Westbrook and just a quick flip
there by Paul George over to the wing
knocks down the three-point shot for the
net so you still have 3.1 seconds left
but Paul George wide open on that
because both players had attacked
Russell Westbrook with that handoff
Sarich Roach it up
bounces off the back of the rim is the
Thunder inching closer up ahead
[Applause]
by pg-13 nobody can stop that get above
the rim forsen Tom Thibodeau and the
t-wolves can take a timeout
Thunder inching closer was 710 to go in
the second did not think the date was
gonna end with in Lorenzo Williams
reference you can get the production Oh
Paul George and again Marcus it's the
bounce passes that are too slow to get
through the quickness here in this
quarter Paul George to Mike beautiful
pass and George with the slam fuchsine
OnPoint delivery little backdoor play
and Russell Westbrook delivers the pass
Paul George
you got to think Paul George has to get
a touch at some point and he does the
three-ball quickly on the job
incredible now watch him come off that's
married comes off the screen and then he
goes up right away you say well what
happened Butler was a half a step back
why because the screen is a big screen
by Adams now you still have to make the
shot that was an incredibly great shot
watch
Paul George now with 30 points
remember we I was worried about him
early on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but what a denial on the defensive end
by Paul Jorgen you talk about access
denied at the rim Paul George just
perfect timing there's George puts it on
the floor gets passed to
[Applause]
[Music]
near the truck and they make the call
George oh my goodness
Paul George bouncing off of Isaac
unbelievable right here what Jonathan
Isaac there's the bump
hands up goodness but as soon as he
feels the contact letting that one go
although we did see as I mentioned last
year fouls called steel steel right here
George what Yanis understand is you want
to get some buckets in an all-star game
start with dunks and layups get the easy
ones first right there a beautiful pass
by Fiji what a season he's having I know
KC himself skipped one foot dirt to dirt
thereby pardon
giorgia here's the reverse 360 the road
s was shot it ends up being comfortable
anyway in a prank away for George
[Applause]
how about that overtime game three
minutes left down to it you go with a
windmill Thunder down one have a timeout
they're not going to use it George with
five George drives over the bear
[Music]
b.p caliber shot by an MVP candidate
split into couples and then over one of
the best shot blockers in the league
rainbows that one in that give the
Thunder the advantage teardrop
[Music]
that was up there butter by the shot
clock right there de that scrape the sky
on the way down Wow drop
[Music]
know what up it's your boy Adam left go
hit that subscribe button for more
content from Br